[Musique]
bonsoir lundi 18 novembre bienvenue pour
cette nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 voici les titres de ce
journal le 30 le 20 novembre 1989 l'onu
adopté la convention internationale des
droits de l'enfant document célébrer
toute cette semaine et dans les villes
yvelinoise avec des animations spéciales
mais trente ans après les droits des
enfants sont ils vraiment respectée elle
nous poserons la question à notre invité
la semaine prochaine l'estaca
accueillera l'événement paris serait
john horizon cyber objectif valoriser la
cybersécurité faire connaître les
initiatives régionales en la matière
elle nous parlerons de ce rendez vous
avec un acteur majeur basé sur le
territoire airbus et cyber sécurité
france et puis l'essentiel des résultats
sportifs
à suivre à la fin de cette édition avec
la qualification notamment est du
football-club de versailles pour le 8e
tour de la coupe de france et
j'accueille tout de suite mon premier
invité sur ce plateau philippe j'en ai
cancon soir bonsoir
représentant de l'unicef l'uni 7,78 le
comité des yvelines on parle avec vous
bien sûr à des 30 ans de la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
[Musique]
mais puisque mercredi se fera trente ans
jour pour jour que ce document a été
adopté à l'organisation des nations
unies mais les célébrations se déroulent
toute cette semaine dans les yvelines le
programme à suivre dans quelques minutes
trente ans pour cette convention plus
que qu'est ce que ça signifie
ça représente beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de travail et surtout ce qui
est important c'est l'amélioration une
amélioration pour des millions d'enfants
qui aujourd'hui on voit leur taux de
mortalité nettement baissé en 30 ans mal
le taux de mortalité infantile a été
divisé par deux ça représente des
millions des centaines de millions
d'enfants qui peuvent aller à l'école
même dans les pays très reculée très
pauvre c'est l'une des missions de
l'unicef de d'éduquer les enfants parce
que sans éducation bas il n'y a pas de
vie sociale possible ni d'avenir pour
eux encore moins possible c'est puis
c'est aussi bien évidemment savoir
répondre aux urgences répondre aux
urgences ça peut être des guerres des
conflits il faut venir sauver et
protéger ses enfants
et puis ça peut être des catastrophes
naturelles comme les séismes les
ouragans les typhons les ont là encore
le lissage pu agir dans les 72 ans de 72
heures après une catastrophe naturelle
on a un centre qui coordonne l'ensemble
des matériels ans aux pays bas et en 72
heures on peut être sûr parce quand il y
as besoin
croquant donc pour ce document un traité
qui a été adoptée le 20 novembre 1989
par l'assemblée générale des nations
unies bonsoir mélanie potier et c'est un
document qui a été adopté à l'unanimité
ouais c'est mes vacances ont su signer
d'imaginer grégory 195 est acquis
ratifier ce traité
seuls les états unis et la somalie n'en
font pas partie encore est ce que c'est
la première fois qu'un texte
international reconnaît les moins de 18
ans comme des êtres à part entière c'est
un texte qui comporte 54 articles on ne
va pas tous les énumérer ici mais il ya
des points principaux à robin haase et
points principaux ils sont quatre et
être en avance et la non-discrimination
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant le droit
de vivre survivre et le respect de
l'opinion de l'enfant on peut aussi
ressortir plusieurs droits quand même le
droit d'avoir un an une nationalité une
identité
le droit d'être soigné protéger des
maladies d'aller à l'école
être pro de l'été j'ai de la violence de
la maltraitance de ne pas faire la
guerre ou encore parce que ce sont des
enfants de jouer et d'avoir des loisirs
et si l'on devait tirer un bilan sur ses
trente ans est ce que la convention est
complètement respecté aujourd'hui alors
l'invitée a déjà donné quelques pistes
parce que bien sûr en trente ans de
nouveaux sujets sont apparus les
conditions climatiques sont très
importantes avec les sécheresses et les
et les inondations d'un retour de la
malnutrition notamment l'eau se fait
rare
plus de 500 millions d'enfants vivent
dans des régions régulièrement touché
par des dix ans des inondations la
sécheresse et près de 160 millions
d'enfants qui vivent dans des régions
concernées la scolarité est aussi
perturbée pour 75 millions d'entre eux
qui ont dû se réfugier alors la france
et c'est le cas pour tous les pays
signataires signataire doit remettre
chaque tous les cinq ans par don au
comité des droits de l'enfant
un rapport et sa dernière audition a eu
lieu en 2016 alors là la france à être
un peu épinglé par l'onu sur la
situation notamment des enfants migrants
l'utilisation des tests osseux pour
déterminer l'âge de seize adolescents
migrants la discrimination raciale
envers les enfants roms
l'absence de données chiffrées sur la
maltraitance alors l'onu recommandé
notamment que les châtiments corporels
soit formellement interdit ça c'est
chose faite le 2 juillet 2019
la france devient le 56e pays à
interdire la fessée
merci mélanie pour ces éléments philippe
journée quand mélanie le disait
finalement cette convention c'est le
premier texte à reconnaître reconnaître
les enfants comme des êtres à part
entière avec des droits aussi des droits
fondamentaux obligatoire et non
négociable ça a vraiment changé la donne
ce texte
seulement je tiens absolument à saluer
le résumé que tu viens de faire mélanie
c'est tout tout est exact dans cette
convention est extrêmement importante
dans la mesure où ce qui est dit là ce
sont des mots mais en fait
ça entre les pays qui adoptent cette
convention doit fait entrer dans leurs
propres lois dans leur propre
législation
ce qui est indiqué que c'est
contraignant son plan juridique c'est
qu'on tristesse unis s'engagent absolue
de série s'engage alors bien évidemment
on voit bien que tous les pays même
s'ils ont signé la convention ne se sont
pas encore engagés sont un peu en retard
et c'est pourquoi il faut toujours
remettre se mettre à l'affût de tout ce
qui ne va pas être je dirais le porte
parole des enfants qui n'ont pas la
possibilité d'avoir la parole qu'ils
sont trop pauvres qui ne sont pas
écoutés et donc c'est nous avons un rôle
fondamental
même en matière de vaccination on se
peut se dire qu'en trente ans la variole
et pratiquement et et éradiquer la polio
est en passe est en passe de l'être
mais il suffit qu'on baisse les bras
pour que ces maladies renesse donc il ne
faut surtout pas arrêter alors qu'on est
tout proche du succès c'est finalement
un socle de travail ce document pour les
actions de l'unicef c'est un socle de
travail qu'il faut faire respecter et
même en france
ça peut paraître surprenant mais
aujourd'hui sont des enfants migrants
notamment sur la situation des enfants
migrants sur la situation des enfants
roms qui ne peuvent pas être inscrits
dans toutes les écoles primaires
alors que l'école primaire est l'une des
bases fondamentales que soutient
l'unicef écoles primaires et gratuite
des enfants ne peuvent pas aller à
l'école
certains même en france des handicapés
souffrent de discrimination donc il faut
se battre pour ses enfants toujours se
battre pour ses enfants
qui faut qu'ils seront les adultes de
demain si un enfant n'est pas bien dans
sa peau à l'âge quand il est enfant
il sera encore moins bien quand il est
adulte il aura envie de se révolter et
c'est donc c'est pourquoi l'action de
l'unicef est toujours et toujours
présente est toujours important nous
sommes en france les interlocuteurs des
pouvoirs publics
nous allons à la rencontre des pouvoirs
publics des députés des maires des du
président de la république qui a reçu
l'année dernière un certain nombre
d'enfants choisi par l'unicef qui ont
exprimé exposé qui lui ont exposé leurs
problèmes leurs envies et ses c'est bien
mais il faut aller jusqu'au bout il faut
que emma la france aujourd'hui donne
encore un petit façon pour un petit
effort et il ya une illustration
flagrante mélanie a parlé du rapport qui
est remis tous les cinq ans à un comité
de l'enfance des nations unies qui a des
gens ont déjà épinglé la france
eh bien cette fois c'est le défenseur
des droits jacques toubon qui remettait
son rapport sur le droit de linge sur
les droits des enfants
aujourd'hui au président de la
république emma jacques toubon défenseur
des droits donc a indiqué je ne cite que
les droits de l'enfant ne peuvent pas
être respectée si les institutions n'ont
pas les moyens de le faire et il
souligne que c'est le cas même en france
des institutions n'écoute pas les
suffisamment les enfants n'écoutent pas
la parole de l'enfant alors que c'est
dans la convention
les paroles les enfants ont le droit à
la parole on doit prendre en
considération leurs desiderata justement
en france mais c'est aussi le cas dans
le monde entier en 2002 l'association
des maires de france et l'unicef se sont
unis pour créer une charte ville amie
des enfants 12 villes pionnières ont
signé cette charte dont saint germain en
laye versailles dans les yvelines
aujourd'hui le réseau comptabilise 245
ville dans la france et 15 dans notre
presse dans notre département
14 dans notre département voilà la
correction a pu l'être en direct ça
alors on découvre ce que signifie ce
cette charte et son application a eu en
cours et montigny le bretonneux avec
marylène iapichino 13 communes ont signé
la charte ville amie des enfants dans
l'est
yvelines dans l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines elles sont trois
directions guyancourt ce jour là les
membres du conseil municipal des enfants
participent à un atelier sur le
harcèlement scolaire avec les policiers
dans le cadre du label ville amie des
enfants il ya une des thématiques et la
participation des enfants et des jeunes
de la ville et le conseil municipal des
enfants c'est ça les enfants viennent
pour mettre en place des projets pour
les enfants de la ville
parmi ces projets la création d'un jeu
c'est un jeu de société pour
sensibiliser sur tous les enfants et les
adolescents au harcèlement la ville de
guyancourt est l'une des premières de
l'agglomération à être entré dans ce
réseau ville amie des enfants en 2006 ce
réseau permet effectivement un certain
nombre de mutualisation de bonnes
pratiques au travers de temps des
changes de temps de mutualisation mais
aussi de rencontres annuelles
le principe est donc de mettre en place
des politiques publiques favorables à la
jeunesse de promouvoir la déclaration
internationale des droits de l'enfant à
montigny le bretonneux les centres
périscolaires sont justement en pleine
préparation d'une journée spéciale pour
les 30 ans de la déclaration le vin
nouveau
[Musique]
on est en train de faire un clip pour la
chanson dont ledroit la chanson ça parle
des droits de l'enfant ont le droit
d'être protégés de soigner d'avoir une
nationalité la loi de bien manger d'être
le j'ai éduqué réalisation d'un clip
vidéo mais aussi d'une fresque avec le
logo de l'unicef
c'est important de fêter les 30 ans de
la convention internationale avec les
enfants qu'ils soient pas et qui soit
participatif sur cette journée montigny
le bretonneux fait partie du réseau
villes amies des enfants depuis 2012 n'a
toujours fait beaucoup puisque c'était
quand on a eu baby boom dans les années
80 il fallait ouvrir des écoles
construire des crèches etc
investir des enfants au coeur du
fonctionnement de la ville au travers
d'un conseil municipal dédié pour eux
organiser des activités ludiques et
éducatives sur les temps périscolaires
autant d'éléments pour entrer dans le
réseau ville amie des enfants un accord
avec l'unicef qui se renouvelle à chaque
mandat municipal
cet engagement des villes fils vont
n'est qu'en pour le droit des enfants à
l'art au travers on l'a vu de
différentes actions pourquoi c'est
nécessaire pourquoi c'est important
c'est un vecteur essentiel pour nous ça
nous permet de mateur autres recruter
des bénévoles parce qu'on a besoin de
bras pour vous mener des actions est
allé à la rencontre de des citoyens qui
habitent yvin pas c'est très important
c'est comme ça qu'on recrute par ci par
là qu'on peut mener d'autres actions
multiplier le nombre d'actions et
j'espère que ma cette année encore grâce
à ces manifestations et je vois montigny
par exemple à montigny le bretonneux il
ya une série de 2
d'animation qui se font au sein de la
mairie pour préparer ces journées c'est
semaine dans l'exemple l'unicef apporte
un jeu de l'oie le jeu de l'oie de
l'unicef qui sera donc dans la mairie
c'est normalement pour les 6 12 ans mais
même les parents qui peuvent venir
peuvent apprendre et à travers ce jeu on
apprend un petit peu à découvrir la cei
de la convention internationale des
droits de l'enfant les différents
articles
il ya des questions sur l'éducation la
protection l'alimentation l'importance
de l'eau c'est ludique mais on apprend
des on apprend vraiment beaucoup
merci philippe bond des commandes est
repassée en plateau et je rappelle que
vous êtes représentant de l'unicef 70
alors vous en parliez justement à
l'occasion des 30 ans de la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
des événements se tiennent dans tout le
département
le programme dans l'agglomération
saint-quentinoise à partir de demain
elancourt organise sa semaine spéciale
conférences ateliers avant une journée
de clôture samedi prochain la veille
vendredi 22 novembre guyancourt propose
aussi une journée spéciale autour des
droits de l'enfant c'est au pavillon
waldeck rousseau et les communes de
maurepas et de montigny le bretonneux
elle se mobilise le jour exact des 30
ans de la convention internationale
c'est le 20 novembre chansons danses et
des bas au menu enfin attrape aussi se
joint aux célébrations avec une semaine
dédiée qui se déroule jusqu'au 26
novembre qui va consacrer la journée du
27 novembre au droit des enfants à la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant
le message est passé alors je parlais de
trappes justement samedi à la ville
trappistes accueilli un forum consacré
aux droits de l'enfant c'était à la
salle jean baptiste clément un rendez
vous initié par l'association atd quart
monde
maryline iapichino et mathilde et demi
dix associations se sont réunies pour
les parents et les enfants de la ville
de trappes qui ont pu re découvrir
autour de jeux et de témoignages la
convention internationale des droits des
enfants autour de la table les jeunes
discutent entre eux et liste leurs
droits
creel ibovi droit ce que l'arrêté et
protection les en prison pas de droite
on a droit à tout j'ai droit à être
respectés
[Musique]
je dois avoir un prénom et un nom mois
plus tard j'aimerais faire un métier je
revienne
je suis très impatient de
lors d'ateliers les enfants prennent
connaissance de leurs droits tout en
s'amusant même si la convention des
droits des enfants fête ses 30 ans
certains droits ne sont toujours pas
respectés il ya encore des beaucoup de
progrès à faire
parce que il ya encore des enfants à la
rue alors qu'ils devraient être logés
avec leurs familles
il y a encore des enfants qui échappent
aux mailles de l'éducation en
particulier d'un les gens du voyage en
particulier et donc il y a encore des
progrès à faire au niveau de la santé
aussi certains enfants ne sont pas bien
soigné un forum qui permet de donner la
parole aux enfants mais aussi aux
parents qui rencontrent des difficultés
au quotidien des associations défenseur
des droits qui luttent pour avoir des
aides pour les enfants défavorisés
abandonnés ou handicapées l événement se
déroulera mardi 26 novembre à l'estac à
l'école d'ingénieurs basée à montigny le
bretonneux paris serait john horizon de
cyber est la conférence francilienne de
la cyber sécurité pour en parler un
grand acteur un de du secteur à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonsoir
frédéric bull
bonsoir vous êtes le directeur d'airbus
cybersécurité france dont les locaux
sont situés à elancourt les objectifs de
cette conférence d'abord c'est de
valoriser ce secteur de la cybersécurité
oui alors c'est un secteur qui est en
perpétuelle mutation et l'idée de la
conférence est de montrer comment on
peut innover à plusieurs et c'est
surtout le sens de montrer la
coopération qui est indispensable dans
ce secteur y compris parfois entre deux
très gros acteurs comme c'est notre cas
puisqu'on et airbus hiver sécurité
implantée à 51 plus de 300 personnes et
des pme innovantes
on parlera notamment d'un projet que
vous avez développé avec l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines convention
qui a été signée pack lits dont on en
parle juste après on voit bien cette
thématique de la cybersécurité avec
toutes les actualités récentes autour
des cyberattaques c'est une thématique
importante
quels sont les enjeux autour de la
cybersécurité en avant de nombreux si on
si on peut les résumer en fait il ya des
grandes sociétés qui sont des cibles
d'attaqués importantes qui sont
mondiales en fait il ya différentes
échelles dans la cybersécurité
donc c'est pour ça que l'état a pris en
main ça en protégeant ce qu'on appelle
les opérateurs d'importance vitale et en
exigeant des niveaux de protection élevé
vous êtes un premier enjeu il faut
savoir qu'il ya des groupes d'attaquants
dans le monde entier il faut arriver à
les détecter et ces choses qu'on fait
depuis saint quentin depuis elle en
cours les morceaux entre de sécurité
d'elancourt et aprilia deux types
d'enjeux parce qu'il ya plein d'acteurs
qui sont des cibles possibles comme par
exemple les pme elles mêmes et là il n'y
a pas forcément suffisamment à la fois
de d'entraînement à la cyber il ya on
peut manquer encore de solutions
pratiques pour ces types d'entreprises
et c'est aussi un axe sur lequel on
travaille beaucoup avec les pms que
c'est un secteur qui a encore du mal à
trouver ses collaborateurs alors il ya
plus en plus de formations qui se
développe autour de la cybersécurité est
ce qu'il ya un enjeu aussi peut-être un
besoin en recrutement
aujourd'hui alors tout à fait on estime
aujourd'hui ses études mondiales 1 qu'il
manquera plus de 2 millions d'experts un
cyber en 2022 donc ça c'est lié au fait
que les surfaces dataco demande sans
arrêt les cibles augmentent sans arrêt
et pratiquement toutes les offres
maintenance en digital donc elles sont
vulnérables aux attaques
donc pour ça nous on a une option tout à
fait concrète lors qu'ils souhaitent
plusieurs façons notamment un outil qui
permet de simuler des attaques et
d'entraîner les ingénieurs donc on a
passé de nombreux accords avec des
écoles d'ingénieurs
c'est assez rare un codé des sociétés
qui qui qui offre des services
c'est aussi des alliances avec des
écoles car ça c'est la cyber anges qui
en fait un espèce de deux systèmes de
simulation qui permet à la fois de
simuler des choses qu'on attaque et des
modes d'attaqué donc ça permet
d'entraîner très efficacement et puis on
annoncera prochainement un accord avec
un grand acteur de la formation skil
s'agit aussi de faire la formation
continue en cybersécurité alors l'autre
objectif de l'événement c'est de mettre
en avant vous le disiez des initiatives
régionales locales en matière de
cybersécurité entre des acteurs publics
et privés vous avez par exemple avec
saint quentin en yvelines signé le pack
lido en février en somme c'est tester
des solutions de cybersécurité avec des
acteurs universitaires c'est ça les
grêlons mais aussi économique puisqu'il
ya des petites sociétés ya des
laboratoires des acteurs
universitaire et airbus est en fait on
test grandeur réelle donc saint quentin
est un territoire d'expérimentation et
en fait c'est la sécurisation d'internet
des objets vous savez ces relations
multiples entre des objets connectés
ça peut être et éclairage public etc et
saint quentin et le théâtre
d'expérimentations de cette multi packs
lido qui est vraiment très innovant et
si on va jusqu'au bout c'est quelque
chose qui peut être déployée à grande
échelle dans la vocation d'airbus d'air
sécurité de mener ses projets au local
même si finalement vos clients sont à
l'international c'est vraiment le sens
de la cybersécurité c'est la coopération
à différents niveaux faut être capable
de faire de la coopération locale et la
coopération internationale ont fait les
deux alors l'activité chez airbus
cybersécurité qui est donc spécialisée
dans la protection du de données vous
parliez tout à l'heure de ce service
pour lutter contre les cyberattaques le
security operations center qui oeuvrent
7 jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24
4 donc fait à l emploi juste à côté nous
en fait on protège trentaine de clients
en permanence alors ils ont des as est
enfin des choses à protéger dans le
monde entier et donc depuis ce centre h
24 on détecte les attaques et on y
répond ça devient quelque chose de tout
à fait essentiel être capable de
détecter ne suffit pas de protéger faut
détecter les attaques extrêmement
discrète ce qu'on appelle les héros des
temps j'avoue c'est à dire des attaques
nouvelles qui ne sont pas détectés par
des antivirus et c'est simplement
repérant des choses anormales dans des
milliards d'informations qu'on arrive à
les allées découvrir tout ça c'est notre
vie avec la protection de l'est
notamment pour les institutions
européennes
ça oui en fait depuis ce même centre on
protège également les institutions
européennes tout cas plusieurs d'entre
elles via un contrat européen qu'on a
remporté il ya trois ans vient alors
dernière question là les actualités vous
le disiez vous vous apprêtez à signer un
nouveau partenariat c'est ça tout à
l'heure alors en temps on n'a pas vu
l'actualité donc il ya un partenariat de
formation que je faisais avec un
contacteur mais il ya aussi un
partenariat qu'on a signé avec la
société thalès assez c'est assez
original parce qu airbus cyber security
et thales peuvent être des concurrents
mais dans le domaine encore une fois de
la sibérie faut s'allier et on a en
allemagne sur le marché des moyens
détection tout à fait nouveau assez
unique même sur le marché mondial entre
une sonde de thales et des moyens de
détection intelligente que nous
art donc ça on l'a annoncé il ya
quelques semaines et on va bientôt avoir
une nouvelle annonce aussi pour notre
sens de détection de saint quentin on
essaye de d'être en permanence en
évolution ce sera merci frédéric eu
l'entrée passée en plateau directeur
d'airbus cybersécurité france airbus
cyber sécurité qui participera donc à la
paris serait john morrison scheiber la
conférence francilienne sur la
cybersécurité inquiète au programme le
26 novembre
et c'est à l'estac a parlé des offres et
de la stratégie de l'immobilier
d'entreprise sur le territoire de paris
saclay la thématique d'une matinée de
conférences organisées par
l'établissement public d'aménagement en
fin de semaine dernière l'événement se
tenait en essonne à massy dans les
locaux du à crédit agricole consumer
finance est les détails de nicolas
landry ils sont promoteurs immobiliers
dirigeants d'entreprise ou directeur
développement économique pour une
intercommunalité
près d'une centaine de professionnels
ont participé à la conférence territoire
d'opportunités paris saclay sur
l'immobilier d'entreprise
l'occasion de parler de la stratégie du
cluster faucon répondre à l'ensemble des
besoins est clairement ils sont en
évolution donc on est nous en
perpétuelle réflexion sur comment
répondre à ces nouveaux besoins à ces
nouveaux usages qu'ils répondent en fait
un nouveau profil d'entreprise la
diversité caractérise les trois
communautés d'agglomération qui
composent paris saclay notamment saint
quentin en yvelines territoire
économique ne plus de 40 ans composée de
4,6 millions de m² d'immobilier
d'entreprise avec plusieurs projets de
réhabilitation pour s'adapter aux
nouveaux besoins des entreprises c'est
très important pour les entreprises
d'avoir à l'heure actuelle que ce soit
pour des petites entreprises ou des
grosses entreprises elles ont toutes
besoin de locaux modulables et flexible
c'est vraiment pour faciliter en fait le
travail en commun la collaboration ou
l'innovation et rendre les choses
beaucoup moins statique qu'elle l'était
avant avec des bureaux individuels par
exemple pour l'innovation on a besoin de
lieux un peu hybride et oui donc
maintenant toutes les entreprises ont
vraiment besoin de ces lieux là une
adaptation qui permet à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de rester
dynamique dans ce secteur en 2018 plus
de 222 1000 mètres carrés ont fait
l'objet de transactions immobilières sur
le territoire
[Musique]
on termine ce journal par les principaux
résultats sportifs du week-end avec
miquel et demi d'euros bonsoir
journalistes aux sports de la rédaction
de tv 78 on va commencer par du football
et on jouait la coupe de france ce
week-end le 7e tour de la coupe de
france même versailles dernier club
yvelinois en lice continue l'aventuré
versailles et sont revenus de leur
voyage à la réunion avec une victoire
dans leur valise se sont imposés 3-2
contre l' us sainte marie les hommes de
la cité royale revenue au score à deux
reprises ont marqué dans les dernières
minutes du temps additionnel sur penalty
à la 95e minute de jeu regarde la
réaction dans les vestiaires
[Applaudissements]
le tirage au sort du prochain tour aura
lieu cette semaine la rencontre soit
programmé le samedi 7 ou le dimanche 8
décembre
on croise les doigts on continue à
parler football un petit peu au-delà des
divisions plus basse le championnat de
première division de district avec un
choc qui étaient au programme
oui ils ont été sortis la coupe de
france très tôt dans la compétition
voisins et gargenville deux équipes dans
le top 3 de la division s'affrontaient
ce dimanche le 17 novembre sur le
terrain de voisins-le-bretonneux après
une phase d'observation la première
période et finalement remporté par les
visiteurs gargenville marque deux buts
en contre 2 à 0 à la mi-temps deuxième
période voisin poussent pour revenir au
score
ce sont finalement les joueurs de
gargenville qui creuse l'écart avec un
troisième but 3 0 ce sera le score final
on écoute la réaction de ioana michely
seconde mi-temps était mieux on a
commencé à rentrer dans notre compte
malheureusement ça faisait 45 minutes
que match avait débuté mais bon c'était
c'était beaucoup mieux
après on a un peu manqué d'efficacité
puis on prend un but dans les arrêts de
jeu un peu anecdotique pour rebondir à
voisins bretons ne tentera de s'imposer
sur le terrain de bois d'arcy le
dimanche 24 novembre de son côté et
gargenville se rendra sur le terrain de
sartrouville
on termine par du cyclisme pendant la
soirée à deux galas star en piste
organisé au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les
spectateurs ont notamment pu assister à
un record philippon c'est un sportif
atteint de broncho-pneumopathie
chronique obstructive d'une maladie de
poumon a réussi à parcourir plus de 27,1
kilomètres sous assistance respiratoire
objectif sensibiliser le grand public
sur sa maladie qui touche 4 millions de
personnes en france s'en trouvera un
caucus un peu plus générale avec des
interviews aussi sur cet évènement
michael dans votre émission le cetud
sport c'est à suivre dans quelques
instants sur tv 78 voilà c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi on se
quitte en musique on a le droit c'est le
titre écrit par le rappeur kurt a
interprété par les enfants
la de montigny le bretonneux à
l'occasion des 30 ans de la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
belle soirée sur tv 78
trente ans déjà que la convention des
droits de l'enfant fut adoptée en temps
déjà trente ans déjà que nous
on le droit la liberté oui on a le nez
protéger
soigner
g
[Musique]